controllers
[Music]
Welcome to our press conference
following the EU select Summit and a
special Welcome to our guests the
president of Argentina and the prime
minister of Saint Vincent and the
Grenadines
I'll first give the flow to the
president of the European Council please
thank you thank you very much and good
afternoon
to all of you
we feel we have really achieved our duty
today that we are seeing a new
optimistic positive chapter open in
relations between EU and silac
we have uh just uh
agreed on a declaration on both sides an
ambitious declaration that covers a vast
uh
scope of uh areas for future development
this was supported by all countries with
the exception of one that couldn't agree
to one single paragraph so that was the
success of this event we have worked
seriously and intensely on all of the
different points on our agenda which
include all of the different issues
relating to climate change biodiversity
the different challenges relating to the
green transition the digital transition
also working on areas of Economic and
trade cooperation the subject of
Investments as well and acting together
to defend the values and principles that
are close to our hearts the values of
multilateralism we want to have a
multi-poral world they're based on the
principles of the United Nations Charter
the principles of sovereignty and all of
these points were the subject of
in-depth Exchange changes and
discussions and then at the end of this
meeting we adopted our declaration which
is very important for our future as you
know for eight years we've not managed
to meet around the same table but we are
firmly convinced and this is a message
that was generally supported that we
certainly do not want to wait another
eight years to meet again on the
contrary we've said we want to really
breathe a new life into our relationship
and that's why we've decided we should
have a permanent coordination mechanism
and we've decided that every two years
we will be holding a summit at the
highest level let me share with you a
few additional Elements which I think is
worth highlighting this Summit was an
opportunity to have an increasing number
of bilateral meetings there because
aside from the deliberals of this Summit
we've got a commitment on the part of
the member states of the EU and the
member states of Select to mobilize
different Partnerships concrete
proposals to Foster Investments and in
particular we discussed the supply
chains and natural resources this is a
subject which is very important not just
for the EU and we see that there really
is a huge capacity to develop
operational partnership respecting those
principles that are important for the EU
quality Investments the need to have
Fair uh just Partnerships with this
capality capability capacity to develop
in a positive way on both sides and
think this was one of the important
points that was put across by the select
side we've clearly understood that
message and we are very committed to it
I don't want to speak at Great length
you will have the opportunity to read
those declaration but let me just to
close by warmly thanking our colleagues
in particular Ralph gonsalves who is the
extemporary president of look but also
Alberto Fernandez his predecessor thank
you very much for the close cooperation
the Friendship the way we've worked
together which has enabled us to make
Headway and validate this common program
for the future and of course I can't
stand here before you today without
expressing my immense satisfaction we've
had intense discussions at European
level but I'd like to announce that
incorpora we've managed to have an
agreement on principle on the poster new
agreement this is a very important step
we want the legal finalization of this
to happen by the end of this week it's a
success for the rotating Spanish
presidency for prime minister Sanchez
it's very tangible operational result
and I'm sure there will be many other
such examples and it's also a signal to
our friends in Latin America and the
Caribbean we raised this point a lot
yesterday and today and I just want to
share that excellent news with you now
and I'm sure everybody will welcome this
and let me close on a more personal note
it's rather unusual for me to do this
and I hope that my colleagues won't hold
this against me but it's the last uh
press conference for my spokesperson who
I've been working with for over eight
years and I really just wanted to say
thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you president of the European
Council may I now give the floor to the
prime minister of the Saint Vincent and
Grenadines
thank you very much
good evening
brothers and sisters ladies and
gentlemen of the media
I first of all want to thank
the European Union
[Music]
the European Commission
Charles
and um
all the heads of government of the
European Union and of
silac
for being involved in what
will I think turn out to be a historic
Gathering
the relationship between
Sri Lankan the European Union
stronger today
than it was yesterday or the day before
yesterday as a consequence of this
agreement
it's a wide range in agreement of 41
paragraphs
touching and concerning
all the
major contemporary issues
which concern us both regions
selac and
well Europe really remade
the Caribbean and Latin American remade
itself
and each
region each of those respective
civilizations
has to
come to terms with the process of this
remaking and the consequences of this
remaking
and what we have to seek to build is not
only a relationship between states
but a relationship between civilizations
Latin American Caribbean and European
civilizations
we touched on the wide range of
practical issues which
Charles raised
and not everybody got the language which
they wanted
you you would expect that there would be
disagreements and it was hard going to
get the Declaration but we have arrived
at this particular point
issues such an unconcerning climate
change the financing of climate change
the reform of the International
Financial
architecture inclusive sustainable
development some matters which have
Arisen
um out of history for which their
contemporary manifestations of
historical legacies like for instance
slavery and the slave trade
[Music]
um
issues on Ukraine
on other conflicts on on
um the terrible embargo against Cuba and
you know the the
question of
um involvement of the private sector
in in the development of Latin America
the Caribbean in Europe
the issues of
international human rights and good
governance and and multilateralism and
the defense of international law defense
and promotion of international law
fundamental precepts of the chart of the
United Nations made flesh
we have been
not together for eight years in a Summit
and in a sense we can borrow
from a poem I'm sure you know it by
Octavio Paz
Nobel
Laureate for literature from Mexico in
the poem release
where he addresses the question that
we grew
we withered and then we sprouted again
select EU
we grew
we withered and we have no sprouted
again and what we have to do
we have to go
to
our body's edges
amidst the unbounded elements
of the real world of life living on
production thank you very much Charles
on the base of this declaration we have
some
actions to do we have a lot of follow-up
this is really just part of the process
of the renewal and this the the
reaffirmation of the friendship and the
relationship between
Europe Latin America and the Caribbean
um we have spoken a lot over the last
few days and you'll have a lot of
questions I have no doubt to answer to
ask thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you prime minister Madam president
you have the floor thank you very much
thank you very much Alberto thank you
very much Ralph thank you very much
Charlotte indeed it was an excellent
Summit
and it really felt like a new beginning
for Old Friends
we need each other
These are times of great geopolitical
change and like-minded friends like us
need to stand together
we had good deliverance and I want to
focus on the part of Deliverance for our
people and for our businesses
on the first day we launched the global
gateway investment agenda for Latin
America and the Caribbean
we will bring over 45 billion Euro
of how high quality European investment
to Latin America and the Caribbean
more than 135 projects are already in
the pipeline so it's a very good start
now of course together we have to shape
the investment agenda and we have to
decide which sectors which value chains
to prioritize and then we have to
implement and deliver
the range of projects is very wide it
goes from clean hydrogen to critical raw
materials from data cable networks to
mRNA vaccines
important is that and we discussed that
a lot global gateway is not just about
how much we are investing but also about
how we are investing
we want that our investment comes with
the highest environmental and social
standards with transparency about what
is happening
we want to share technology and
knowledge
and the training of local Workforce for
the jobs of the future is one of the
core elements
for us it's important in this investment
and that makes it different
that the local communities benefit from
the value chain the added value produced
there this is also in our interest
because we want reliable and trustworthy
suppliers
this is also the spirit of the bilateral
agreements that we concluded at this
Summit
first we signed a Critic aromaters
agreement with Chile
and we also signed two mous
on energy with Argentina and one with
Uruguay
they are both on green energy and
particular on green hydrogen so truly a
win-win situation for both regions and
both continents
my second point is on the trade
agreements
I am very confident in especially after
these two days that in the coming months
we will be able to wrap up the
negotiations with macro sewer
ambesh ambition is to settle any
remaining differences as soon as
possible and to conclude by the latest
by the end of this year
and I am also confident that we will
continue conclude the negotiations on
the modernized eu-mexico agreement in
the following month
I also welcome strongly the good news on
the postcato new agreement we finally
made it it was a lot of negotiations but
now we found an agreement among the
member states and we will manage to sign
it soon
my final point is on the global impact
of Russia's war against Ukraine
I am deeply concerned about Russia's
move to terminate the Black Sea grain
initiative
despite the efforts of the United
Nations and turkey
the risk is that it brings food
insecurity to so many vulnerable
countries across the globe
the European Union will with all means
continue to work to ensure that food
security for vulnerable people is given
as you know we have complementary the
solidarity Lanes
more than 45 million tons of grain oil
seed and other products have been
exported via the solidarity Lanes
the Black Sea grain initiative added
another 35 million tons
so we will for sure continue bringing
agri-food products out of Ukraine to the
global markets via the solidarity Lane
but it is important that the blocking of
the Black Sea is stopped and that the
export via the Black Sea can
keep on going
we discussed a lot of course the fact
that everybody wants this war to end
and peace needs to be just and enduring
and it needs to be centered and the core
has to be the UN Charter
we discussed the importance of the UN
Charter explicitly
it is the common ground for us
it is there for every single country
with the international law and it is in
all our interest to be very strong on
protecting the international law and
protecting the U.N Charter in this
Spirit we have discussed and it was as I
said an excellent beginning for new
friends to have a new tradition every
two years to meet with senac thank you
very much thank you madam president
president of Argentina you have the
floor thank you very much
good afternoon everyone
my first words are words of gratitude
thank you Ursula thank you Charles thank
you Ralph
and thank you also to my dear friend
Pedro Sanchez the pro-temporary
president of the European Union
you've done a fantastic job
it seemed it was going to be difficult
to bring together so many countries and
get agreement in just two days of work
on so many different issues
given the current situation the issues
that are affecting Latin America and the
Caribbean and the issues that are
affecting Europe as well
this was a very important moment an
ambitious meeting and it really met the
expectations with which many of us came
here
it had been some time since Europe Latin
America and the Caribbean last met
and we managed to meet again after eight
years asylak and the EU
I remember back in 2006
Latin America the EU the Caribbean I
participated in a meeting many years
have gone by since then and I don't
think we've ever had so much agreement
on so many points as we have today so
that's why I'm so happy and So Satisfied
with the outcome of this meeting I think
it's important for our region Latin
America and the Caribbean
on the different points that Ralph was
mentioning there you will see a lot of
expressions from Europe there
acknowledging recognizing problems
points of view from Latin America and
the Caribbean in which we need to
confront today as Ursula said we are all
concerned about the situation of war in
Ukraine quite clearly we are concerned
and the countries of Latin America have
always expressed their desire to work to
re recover peace quickly and that that
should be enduring peace
and we still see today that war is not
the way
within this multilateral world that has
its own bodies
which exist and so we should not repeat
that situation
I'm very happy that we've got the
agreement on energy with Ursula which we
signed yesterday that's very important
for Argentina there's a lot of legal
uncertainty in terms of investments from
Europe and that's certainly of interest
when it comes to energy and I'm also
happy because this was the first time
that we had the opportunity to discuss
in such clear terms uh mechanism that
would take us away from extractivism in
Latin America this whole idea that Latin
America is just a producer of raw
materials
and that has always prevented us from
industrializing that primary production
and this was the first time that we
really crossed the t's and dotted the
eyes and talked about extractivism
and I think it took five centuries but
we managed it and I'm seeing that half
ingest but we have at last succeeded
we now
can look at the products of our land
look at the value of it count on
investments from Europe and that's very
important for us very encouraging
and it's also very encouraging
that we had a very Frank discussion
and at every turn we managed to find
overlap with Europe on Democracy on the
rule of law and on the full respect for
human rights
and these are very solid this is a very
solid basis for the work of our
countries and it's on that basis that we
achieved our agreement so I want to
thank all of you for the efforts made my
dear friend Pedro Sanchez who's
campaigning now and that's why he's not
up here with us
but who did such an important job in
inviting us here he knows how important
the issues are for Latin America he
knows how much respect and admiration we
have for him in Latin America and the
Caribbean as well
and we of course understand why he
wasn't able to attend so thank you very
much to all of you very happy with the
agreement thank you for your hospitality
for all of the efforts and the
hospitality here in Brussels
[Applause]
yes please
good afternoon I'll speak Spanish as it
is the select Summit the first question
is for the president of the council and
either of the two Representatives uh
from select uh Ukraine has become a
problem in the negotiations uh here
between all of the countries we've got
one paragraph in the council conclusions
uh where uh their uh
I wasn't agreement
do you think this has brought into
question uh this Summit
I mean you've got all the other
paragraphs say is this undermining the
whole of the rest of the agreement and
then my second question
on Pedro Sanchez
he's not here today at such an important
Summit uh
because of the Electoral campaign
two points uh the first point is on the
possession of the EU uh on the war
against Ukraine we have uh reiterated
this and each and every uh Summit we
have reiterated our determination to
defend protection of the interests of
Ukraine against this aggression by
Russia and if you look at this
declaration it's now been validated by
both sides you'll read in that
declaration that there are a number of
points that have been expressed that
refer to that situation which is having
an impact on the entire world and you
will also see that there is strong
determination to defend the principles
of multilateralism and world order that
is a rules-based world order that is
absolutely essential and as I indicated
at the start of the meeting we are
absolutely delighted that we were able
to agree on a strong position 60
countries around the table on both sides
EU and selac and together with my
colleague who co-chaired this Ralph
Gonzalez I said there was just one
country that couldn't agree to just one
paragraph in that when you weigh up all
of the different negotiating efforts and
compromises that required in order to
achieve agreement on an international
agenda that is as rich as this that we
had on the table for the Summit is
clearly a huge success and that was
thanks to our diplomatic efforts but
also the mutual trust between ourselves
and the ability that we had not just
today and yesterday but for quite some
time now to really understand their
convictions feelings on both sides and
we were able to develop that position
together then on the Spanish prime
minister I have said since the very
outset that
Spain is very committed
diplomatic effort to prepare this Summit
that takes a long time between all of
the EU member states and the Senate
countries and we've seen there just
a few minutes ago not only did we get
agreement on this declaration but I was
also pleased to announce this agreement
on the post-continue situation as you
know for months we had difficulties and
the E on this subject for months so we
were trying to get consensus amongst
ourselves so I'm delighted as I say that
thanks to our tenacity uh thanks to the
tenacity of the Spanish team under the
lead of Pedro Sanchez they've been able
to reach this agreement which should be
legally implemented by the end of this
week Paula yes from Tere Global in
Brazil Pola
hi good evening it's all Global
newspaper in Brazil I'm just correcting
sorry good evening
um so thank you for doing this I would
like to ask during his speech here
president Lula said that the negotiation
of the agreement between the medical
store and the European Union should be
based on trust and not on threats he
also said that the defense of the
environment should not be an excuse for
protectionism I would like to ask the
Europeans on stage mainly of course
I just could also comment are you
threatening the medical store countries
and are you using the environment as an
excuse to protect your economies thank
you
foreign
is not the way we are working on the EU
side we do not have any hidden agenda we
are extremely transparent and we would
like to strengthen the economic and the
trade ties with the team America and the
Caribbean and the public permission is
very well explained where we stand and
what are our common doors and I'm
absolutely convinced that this high
level meeting today and yesterday was to
do great or change and a great
opportunity to listen to each other to
better understand what are the concerns
on both sides because there are concerns
on both sides for this agreement and I'm
absolutely convinced that we share the
same the same priorities especially uh
concerning the defense of the
biodiversity the important importance to
address so seriously climate change and
one important topic we discussed today
and yesterday is related to the
financing because we understand very
well that the current financing system
is not fair and that's why we are
absolutely determined to work together
also because there will be important
political moments in the month to come
especially at the level of the United
Nations in order to try to make sure
that all the countries across the world
I I assuming their responsibilities what
we are doing on the EU side because this
is absolutely true that for many years
on the U side we think that we need
collectively to be serious in addressing
climate change in the consequences and
many colleagues in Latin America and
Caribbean they share and they absolutely
committed and they can see every day the
consequences of this climate change
topic and this climate change issue
foreign
thank you if I may just add something I
would like to shed some light on two
things
the first
is that prime minister Pedro Sanchez did
a tremendous amount for this meeting and
he was with us until just a moment ago
and then of course he had to go back to
Spain to campaign to uphold the best
democratic values in Spain
so we're very happy that he's doing that
certainly in order and nuisance for us
and then on that question
I'd like to clear up a couple of points
Lula is a friend of mine we work closely
together on this point also together
with the European Union
and the truth of the matter is that once
Lula became president of
Brazil from that moment on we were able
to pick up once again reasonable
dialogue with the European Union there
was a time during which there was no
respect for the Amazon in Brazil and
that was clear to the European Union and
countries such as Argentina that was not
just the point of view of the European
Union it was also the perspective of
Argentina and we see in the agreement
with Luna that there are of course
matters that we need to attend to
we had an agreement in July 2017 then in
December we had the announcement of the
the green deal which will have an impact
on that initial agreement and so of
course we have to come back to certain
points and discuss them with the
European Union Ursula visited me in
Buenos Aires she also went to several
other countries and so we've expressed
those points of concern and we're
continuing to work on them
and so I think we are on the right track
it's a very positive track
towards an agreement but as I said in my
own speech an agreement has to be a
win-win if you have one winner and one
loser it's not a good agreement and so
what we want to do is uphold an
agreement in which everyone is happy
thank you good agreement that we are
negotiating and that both sides are
deeply convinced of the high value of
this agreement
and indeed my travel to Brazil and
Argentina helped a lot to listen and to
understand
what the ideas on Marco's suicide are
and to mirror that with our ideas and
there's a strong consensus we share the
same goals we want the protection of
climate and biodiversity
and president Lula since an office has
made huge progress for example in
stopping deforestation and all this will
be reflected in a shampoo document that
we are just finalizing now
so important was to travel to be there
to speak to each other eye to eye to
listen to each other and to understand
each other's standpoint and since then
for me there's even more clarity that we
will be successful with this agreement
at that and that we will finalize it
thank you madam president yes Luisa from
El Diario nacion de Argentina Luisa
for Sean Michelle
my question is with regard to the format
of the conference
you've all talked about bilateral
agreements and the success of those
agreements whereas for a couple of days
we've seen blocks on the Declaration on
the conference so for future meetings
are you going to keep the same format
would it maybe not be wiser to organize
other formats
such as many Regional summits I don't
know whether that's an interesting idea
or not please tell me whether you think
so well we always look forward to
interesting ideas this format is the 27
member states uh of the year in the 33
members of silac and uh we are there to
reach agreement on very complex uh
essential issues we bring together 60
governments uh representing all their
different peoples and interests and it's
not easy of course it's not easy it's
required a lot of commitment but it's
because there is a clear conviction
around the table that we are united by
many things we have a a stronger
link we are united more united than
divided so after eight years we felt it
was important to have this
meeting this joint declaration and this
is the starting point for this new
chapter and I believe there will be much
closer more regular contact Constant
Contact in the future and it will enable
us maybe to have closer understanding we
can meet again in two years to
strengthen the ties between the EU and
the select region same in relation to
what has been asked by Oda sister
that there have been Regional meetings
of one kind or another involved in the
European Union the Caribbean Central
America
um South American countries on different
subjects
but but clearly
it is vital that the political
leadership
the political leaderships in Latin
America and the Caribbean the European
Union to give life and Direction and
meaning to this relationship at the
highest level you have to meet from time
to time this is a terrible thing that we
hadn't met for eight years now we're
going to meet the next time we're going
to meet in Colombia the agreements the
declaration has said that in 2025. and
and silac itself has put itself in a
position where it can look forward
to these kinds of meetings in a more
structured way for instance
um there's already an agreement in silac
that
a Honduras will succeed in Vincent and
Wendy's next year as the PTP of Silas in
Colombia will succeed here we had a
meeting with the the Troika the
immediate pass PTP of silac then myself
Honduras plus one the the the chair of
CARICOM of the Caribbean community so
but but what this meeting has been about
is to provide leadership if I may just
say something which connected with one
of the questions which was asked earlier
in relation to climate change
paragraph 23 of this declaration says
this we stress the importance to fulfill
the commitment by developed countries
jointly to mobilize U.S 100 billion
dollars per year for climate Finance to
support developing countries and to
double adaptation Finance by 2025. well
there was this
um promise made in Stockholm in 2009 and
and that we should start something by
2020. nothing has happened now we are
having the 27 countries of the European
Union saying hey
we are going to push and do something
about this
no this is an important declaration now
we have to work through
details on these matters and there's
several other such paragraphs
um I know
that from time to time it is in the
nature
of human beings particularly and and
it's good for journalists to be cynical
uh because it is stocking trade
but but but but there's great promise
here and um
I I think we should
not suspend our judgment as to what is
here
but to hold
us and particularly the Europeans in
this case because they have more
resources to hold their feet to the fire
so that I mean it would be an awful
thing if you write this in paragraph 23
and then in 2025 we see no money
that would be a hell of a thing
then your sinner system would be
justified
thank you prime minister yes Ian from uh
from the Ft another question
thank you very much Ian Johnston
Financial Times uh just to come back to
the paragraphs on Ukraine uh does the
last 48 hours show that despite 18
months of War documented war crimes by
Russia Europe can still not convince
some countries in the global South to
unite behind a condemnation of Russia's
Invasion and to prime minister Gonzalez
Gonzalez and president Fernandez
hasn't been too much of a focus on
Ukraine at this Summit has that used up
energy that could have been dedicated to
other issues such as climate change
trade relations absolutely not
absolutely not I can tell you straight
from the very beginning I said to
Charles
we cannot make this Summit between the
European Union and silac Bs Summit on
Ukraine
but clearly
Ukraine is a matter
of great importance
to Europe and the world other conflicts
too
um in in in the world and if you read
the paragraph on Ukraine
you would see
what is said here paragraph 15 we
express deep concern on the going war
against Ukraine and then the detail that
great concern then that par that section
of the paragraph says we support all
diplomatic efforts in that adjust and
sustainable peace in line with the UN
Charter then it goes on to recognize the
national positions of the various
governments as Adam britted in the as UN
General Assembly resolutions and and it
it ends it is essential to uphold
international law
and the multilateral system that
safeguards peace and stability so
there's a reaffirmation of positions and
a ticking of the box it doesn't mean
that you have to go into the Lambada in
the nude anytime a subject is raised
it's not a is
you know if the language is there I mean
I don't know what what
what what we need to do more more more
than this to to to get the attraction of
um of of of
um persons they clearly
we have concerns
um
Europe has concerns about Ukraine the
concerns for us in Ukraine among other
things would be the terrible suffering
that has taken place among peoples who
are directly involved in the conflict
but also because of increase in prices
shortages of Commodities increasing
immigration of people as a consequence
not of only of the war but of the
sanctions consequent upon the war and
all of these things and we need to make
the world a better place I mean and and
uh but but you are responsible people we
have we put things down in words I know
in these you know that we you don't have
to go and dramatize anything just you
put it in clear and precise language and
mean what you say simple as that
thank you prime minister
Tomaso yes from Adian Kronos
yes good afternoon
it's just a question uh I apologize to
go back to the war in Ukraine but given
that Cardinal matosu is being received
to the White House if you're not
mistaken
do you see I mean a movement towards uh
or a deal or something
similar to a solution for the war
because we are heading slowly towards
the U.S elections of 2024. thanks
you want to address that question to
whom exactly to muscle
is
perhaps two things and I think this will
link up with the previous question as
well
first of all
the European Union supports a just peace
formula
because it is anchored in the charter of
the United Nations and the sovereignty
of the territory of Ukraine and also It
Is Anchored In Justice that we need
accountability for such severe acts that
are committed
and that's an international matter so
that's the position on Ukraine and I
can't speak on behalf of anyone other
than the European Union so that's the
first thing we have very tight
coordination on that position within G7
as well we have very tight coordination
on this topic and then secondly linking
up with the previous question I think
this is essential and I think your
question allows me to be very clear
about this we want to reassert the unity
and the determination of the European
Union vis-a-vis of the situation in
Ukraine and that will not falter and
it's also important to point out to take
note of the fact that our friends in
Latin America and the Caribbean are
upholding international law alongside us
and they've said that Ukraine is an
important security issue for Europe and
the world it's a global matter which is
of extreme importance and that is
brought to the fore so what I'm trying
to say is that we've already given you
our message as a European union and we
have Partners across the globe including
in Latin America and the Caribbean who
and let's not forget we are not blind
to the fact that there are many other
challenges that have not disappeared
since the war broke out climate change
fear international finance
in order to overcome developmental
challenges and poverty or the radical
digital Transformations that have taken
place with the emergence of artificial
intelligence on all of these topics and
all of these challenges which already
existed before this war of aggression
against Ukraine
and of course that's a particular
difficulty the European Union remains
committed to those topics as well as
part of the Partnerships that we have
and I think it's very important that we
bring those messages to the fore as well
and we want our friends in Ukraine to
work alongside us to bring that message
to the other regions of the world as
well all of us we want peace and most of
all the people in Ukraine want peace
they suffer horribly
and I think it was a very good session
that we had today on Russia's war in
Ukraine because
you could feel there's one core
element that keeps us together and where
the common ground is and this is indeed
the U.N Charter and the international
law
and it was born From the Ashes of World
War II so it was born out of a terrible
experience of war and put together in a
system of rules we all subscribed and we
all hold dear we all hold dear because
and this was very strong in the room too
we never know if not tomorrow one of us
needs to call on the U.N Charter to be
protected and therefore I think it was a
very fruitful and good discussion that
we had
um clarifying that we want a just and
Lasting peace and that we have the
common ground with the UN Charter and
with the international law
let me just add this for for so that
there's absolute clarity
look
we are not all children in here and in
fact I don't see any child here
historically we have had a lot of big
Power activities against
smaller poorer countries less powerful
countries
and we see it happen in Latin America
and some who will do things in Latin
America
and the Caribbean and who would raise
when you raise certain
principles of non-interference in the
internal affairs the use of force and
all the rest of it they will ignore you
yet some of those same countries are the
ones who are raising those very
principles in Ukraine so that we have to
get rid of the hypocrisy if we have to
get a better world and let us apply
these principles in the chat of the
United Nations in a clear and objective
Manner and call a speed of spade
whenever the circumstances arise
go
hello
let me just take this opportunity to add
something the first thing is
I'd like it to be clear that this was a
summit between the EU and silac
with political economic cultural ties
between Europe Latin American and the
Caribbean countries
now this meeting took place at the same
time as we have this war between Russia
and Ukraine and I have to say that the
vast majority of the EU and select
countries
condemned in the United Nations the
Russian invasion
and
what I'm trying to say with this is that
there's a lot of media speculation about
this Summit uh saying that it was all
revolving around the war in Ukraine but
no
that's happening of course uh there were
different voices that were expressed
around the table of course there were
but it wasn't the main item on our
agenda we obviously have to make
progress on all of these other points so
let me make it crystal clear here
it wasn't that Latin America was uh
reluctant to speak out against the war
in Ukraine we have done in the United
Nations we have done that
so please put a stop to this media
speculation
gracias
thank you president conference we've
just published
the statement on behalf of events thank
you
foreign